[Music]
hey you guys it's monday yeah i'm
looking at richard harrison yeah that
guy
yeah
well he's like we called horse we
watched the oh yeah yeah that's right we
watched this movie
two nights ago right we didn't watch it
last night we watched the previous night
before zara does yeah and um so tom by
this point had forgotten uh what richard
harris looks like looks like yeah i said
imagine the role and everything but i
couldn't i said
is it because you're picturing quint
from jaws yeah that's yeah i kind of had
the same thing happening pitcher and
quint from jaws and i was picturing
[ __ ] um
uh oh what's his name from the hand uh
michael kane exactly so i was kind of
like shifting between
michael caine and and quint from
harrison i was going no that's not
that's not who it is but then i saw the
i saw him oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah richard harris interesting you
should bring up michael kane because
this movie well actually jaws for the
revenge which had michael caine in it is
kind of a ripoff of this movie like the
plot of it is the same and then i was uh
talking about watching amityville horror
2 last night and went and saw [ __ ]
richard burton his face
exorcist on exodus 2 excuse me what did
i say
amityville i'm not an exorcist yeah
exorcist two and uh saw richard burton's
[ __ ] face we're just inundated by
[ __ ] british drunks
just
so many drunk british [ __ ] all
in the [ __ ] 1970s movies and they
were all scary man all those dudes are
[ __ ] frightening terrifying drunks
they were we were under attack it's a
british new wave terrorizing drugs
now that just gave me a really funny
oliver [ __ ] reed and everything that
just gave me a really very drunk
[ __ ] a really funny uh visual
of kind of like the d-day landing except
it's all like these drunk british dudes
like staggering out of the ocean yeah
they come up
they come up in a damn landing crash
where's that
on the beaches and [ __ ] let all these
[ __ ] drunk british actors out and
occasionally they fall down or throw up
on themselves or something but they just
keep coming
legendary british drunk actors oh my god
yeah we'll see oh i told you to remind
me so i'll probably like just say this
uh right at the jump if you look at the
wikipedia page for orca yeah um it has a
delightful ish story about richard
harris who again not surprisingly was um
allegedly showing up drunk on the set
all the time and he was i guess in his
trailer and was reading a tabloid and
there were pictures in the tabloid of
his wife
uh cavorting on a beach with a much
younger man
and he got so angry that he was going to
quit the movie and fly to malibu to kill
them
and they were like no no it's just calm
down dude
i think harris might have been irish too
huh i'm not sure he was british i think
he might have been irish i think he's
irish yeah i think he lived in in
england probably past well i mean his
accent is irish in this for sure and
like his son jared harris who i didn't
even realize was his son until today
actually is also like a very famous yeah
irish shirt you would probably even know
him if you saw him he's been in like a
[ __ ] ton of stuff he and jay were
talking about these drunk [ __ ]
and uh they were known as drunks even in
england so you have to [ __ ] be
outstandingly drunk to get a reputation
for being a drunk up in that [ __ ] right
there that's kind of what i figured yeah
because they they drink man it's like
hey we're all minor league drunks here
but holy [ __ ] you guys are taking it to
a whole other level
and i think ireland might be the king of
them all
yeah yeah i mean like i said not so much
nowadays but maybe
maybe back in the day
i don't know man fiona was [ __ ] she
could drink me under the table
well that's kind of what they're known
for yeah that's i mean the irish are
kind of known and she could remain
standing
and
the only thing that would [ __ ] let me
know that she was drunk is she would
stop talking
she'd continue drinking now she could
walk she would just stop talking well
she's like after a while she's like all
the talking is getting in the way yeah
yeah yeah yeah her eyes would get
heavy-lit and she wouldn't talk anymore
she just keep drinking
she was amazing delicious booze yeah
yeah she'd start off the [ __ ] beer
and then start moving on the [ __ ]
whiskey
she was the beast
she's a beast yeah
all right so today
in case you didn't uh realize we're
talking about orca
or orca the killer whale with a
exclamation point which i always thought
was funny how do you realize that it has
exclamation on this i didn't know that
either but then like i looked at all the
posters some of the posters just say
orca and then some of them say orca the
killer whale with an exclamation point
yeah um you know because it's exciting
[ __ ] so
basically
i saw this as a kid
and there were a couple scenes in this
that really stuck with me i feel like
this was another one of those movies
that was just on cable all the [ __ ]
time and it's just kind of like every
time you were flipping through the
channels you'd always kind of see part
of it or you'd come in the middle and
then like you'd watch it i don't even
know if i ever actually sat down and
watched the whole thing straight through
i just kept seeing pieces of it over the
years look at how that backlight that
lighting did change the image quite a
bit yeah
yeah she got this new light and it does
it does make the image look a little
crisper yeah i mean it looks good
i thought it did yeah well like i said
it's a ring light but i don't have the
setup and i don't have enough room back
there to like put it around the camera
like you could still see it
um and it was too bright like it doesn't
get dim enough
to be that close like because it's
really really bright so i had to put it
up there yeah hernandez is in there
saying i had a girlfriend back in the
day that could outdrink everyone
tequila's shot after tequila shot
[Laughter]
yeah my my ex [ __ ] fiona back in
boston
straight from cork ireland and [ __ ] was
she was she was a beast
i had i had to quit her
that was part of the problem that was
part of the problem
she'd get mad
she was getting mad eventually once you
get drunk become kind of like a violent
drug man i can't put up with this
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] went down the bar one time and i
met her in that bar it was near my house
and she disappeared one time went and
found her and she was [ __ ] drunk on
the ground
on the floor underneath the damn table
in the middle crowd of people
yeah and then i [ __ ] grabbed her
[ __ ] pulled her out of there wow she
wanted to fight took her home that was
this is
going out with this girl
yeah
thank you gadgey3 been a while have a
fiver by way of apology thank you love
y'all thank you very much
so how this movie came about so i saw
this a bunch growing up um but then i
didn't see it again for a really long
time and so just in the past few weeks
when we've been talking about all these
70s disaster movies and nature run amok
movies and i was kind of like man i'd
really like to see orca again because i
remember
a couple scenes from that really staying
like sticking with me and i remember
that one that you know that was one that
i remembered a lot from when i was a kid
so we wanted to like re-watch it and i
didn't realize how this how this came
about basically
uh this was produced by dino de
laurentiis okay
uh it was actually directed by michael
anderson the same guy that directed
logan's run okay now tell you what
people it does not feel like a dino
flick and it has nothing to do with
logan's ronnie it does not have that
vibe it's more old school more
traditional almost feels like a 60s
movie good
um and so basically
dino de laurentiis was just kind of like
well jaws made all the money yeah so
calls up other producers or
screenwriters or whatever and it's like
okay well what's scarier than what are
bigger and meaner than a great white
shark
uh that we can make you know because he
has to top it obviously
uh
yes
yes
he's italian he's got a well we're going
to make it better they want more of that
we'll get more of that
more bigger yeah yeah [ __ ] flash
gordon oh what's better than that oh
no
what's better than star wars flash
gordon yeah give him more yeah
danny rolling ghostface said this film
was like free willy on steroids yeah so
so it
i guess in a way i think orca obviously
gets
[ __ ] on a lot as a jaws rip-off or a
jaw's cash-in
which it was but
i will say that they didn't cheap out on
this movie uh they did actually put some
effort into it it's got a lot of real
actors in it um anya moricone did the
score for christ's sake uh it's you know
and it's actually nicely shot and they
didn't really do
the thing with
it's not really so much a movie about a
sea creature that's like killing people
for no reason like jaws is it's more
like
a revenge movie
um i've seen it compared to like jaws
meets death wish
because basically this is one of the
only killer animal movies i can think of
where you're actually supposed to be
kind of on the animal side yeah you know
what i'm saying
and i did not remember
that aspect of this story at all and
like i said later jaws 4 of the revenge
kind of had the same storyline yeah i
kind of felt it was supposed to be like
jaws
but they wanted the audience to have a
lot more um empathy for the uh for the
orca than they did the shark yeah and
they tried to they did they basically
did with this what you did with king
kong
yeah king kong is the monster but he's
actually the good guy the humans are the
monsters they brought that [ __ ] on
themselves
they've taken him taking him out of his
[ __ ] island and bringing him to new
york and he's just trying to be a
gorilla you know they end up machine gun
well it's kind of like that
it's an orca just being an orca and dude
goes out [ __ ]
kills this orca's whole family and his
baby and [ __ ] well [ __ ]
and he's got he remembers i'm gonna get
you you know he's he can see up on the
boat he even sees the dude who did it
killing somebody's wife and baby that's
that's the [ __ ] premise for the
punisher that's what i'm saying or death
wish yeah
or like any kind of revenge so that's
why this has been compared in some ways
it's not so much a nature run amok movie
it's more like yeah it's more well it's
more like a revenge flick yeah and you
kind of
i kind of feel like you're supposed to
sympathize more with the orca and i
totally did yeah um or at least they're
trying to make it like even you know
what i mean well now they're trying to
get you to sympathize with the orca
and the dude who did it you know [ __ ]
uh old you know
richard harris richard harris character
he was ignorant to how he kept calling
fish and he was kind of ignorant to what
they were but he had a girl who was a
specialist on him right there telling
hey you know these things are monogamous
you go and kill some of them you might
be bri and capture one of them you're
breaking up a family and you know he's
just like oh well you know and you know
they're gonna [ __ ] i want money even
though in the beginning they give you a
whole class they're showing the brain of
the orca and they go you know it's
comparable to the human brain
you know the size and the shape of it
more than a chimpanzee you know so so
they're letting you know right away that
you this is akin to doing it to a person
i kind of believe that um there's
certain animals that you shouldn't be
killing especially not for food
no
and honestly i don't believe that some
of the [ __ ] that they're happening in
this damn experimental laboratory is
what they're doing to monkeys and dogs
and [ __ ] like that nah not cool at all
not cool at all those are those animals
are
high enough to feel pain and and and
they have little personalities and stuff
you know what i mean i really supposed
to be [ __ ] with them
you know
fish and mice that's not so bad but you
know [ __ ]
that
and that's just be eating whales
leave them [ __ ] whales alone you know
and elephants and [ __ ]
yeah i mean i was
i was curious enough now
i will say this movie yes it came out in
1977 they did oh i i maybe they oversell
how
much of a capacity for vengeance
uh a killer whale would have
but in the movies defense um i looked up
the wikipedia page because i was
interested i'm like well let's see how
much of it over you know over
exaggeration that is not much um they
don't really obviously there's no uh
there's no research on
uh if a killer whale could actually like
recognize you and come and [ __ ] you up
and do some of the [ __ ] that the orca
does in this
but
uh orcas do have really complicated
societies akin to higher primates yeah
uh and elephants so
not you know it's over exaggerated but
not much
the main obstacle that orca would have
is that once you were on land he
couldn't get to you
so you could own they could only get
revenge on you if you were on the ocean
see and that's what kind of killed me
about jaws the revenge which like i said
is essentially the same plot as this it
came out i think 10 years later i think
jaws of revenge came out in 87 if i'm
remembering correctly
but that's the thing it's like well if
there's a shark that's after your family
specifically just don't go in the water
sharks can't breathe air right so you're
fine
um
this one like i said this one's kind of
more like
there's actually i would argue that this
is a better movie than jaws for the
revenge because jobs for the revenge
like i said there's a big plot thing
it's like just don't go in the water
just and don't move somewhere with your
family to the coast while you move to
the midwest where there are no sharks
duh it's problem solved it's actually a
decent movie it's a good movie for the
time it's uh it's shot pretty well but
like i said it does have an older school
feeling it does not feel like a 70s
movie to me feels more like a late 60s
movie the way that it's shot
i don't know if it's the film stock that
they used or just
kind of the dialogue and just uh it's it
would be this would be considered an
old-school kind of classical movie in
the 70s
yeah and it's not newfangled you know
thomas and newfangled no you can
definitely tell this is kind of like
pre steven spielberg pre george lucas
this is the old hollywood really yeah
the old hollywood even though this was
made in response to a stephen spielberg
robbie jaws but not that stuff like i
said it's not really it does have some
similarities with jaws but like i said
it does its own thing it's actually more
of a tragedy
than a killer animal movie we take
spielberg's direction style and editing
for granted because it just feels very
natural to our generation
before that it the stuff before that
kind of had a very blocky mechanical
kind of a
feel to it not very fun uh kind of
paint by numbers it felt like but not
bad just not as
emotional and free-flowing as
steven spielberg
and
they are going against spielberg's grain
or they can't replicate it
probably did the right thing not to
replicate spielberg's style to go more
traditional probably the best better way
to go safer yeah i mean if you're going
to [ __ ] on movies for being jaws
rip-offs even if you just want to do
italian ones there are way worse ones
out there uh devil fish for one which is
actually kind of a hybrid between a
shark and an octopus kind of yeah or a
megalodon or something um the last shark
which is essentially just jaws except
much cheaper and terrible piranha was a
jealous rip off
that these are jaws i mean there are
yeah
jaws i kind of feel like there are more
rip-offs of jaws maybe than any other
movie maybe star wars i don't know
though
uh because look at jaws rip-offs well i
mean look at just up to the present day
look how many movies there are with
sharks in them yeah that you know
obviously they're not all jaws rip-offs
but i don't know in a way they kind of
are i think they kind of are so i kind
of feel like even though this one was
obviously made in response to jaws it's
doing its own thing and i kind of
respect that it does that the reason why
there were so many jaws rip off is jaws
made all the [ __ ] money and well it
was the first blockbuster yeah it made
all the [ __ ] money and it was
kind of like the first spielberg movie
that people really noticed and it was
like wow
it does have a [ __ ] very naturalistic
super american vibe to it but in a good
way
uh
and
that really ingrained itself into the
american
psyche that movie
well it's a lot easier to rip off jaws
on a small budget than it is to rip off
star wars on a low budget yeah that's
true a low budget star wars rip-off is
[ __ ] it looks like [ __ ]
a low-budget jaws rip-off
not all that far from the original
jaws you know what i mean i mean you
could just buy some stock shark footage
yeah you know stock shark footage what
did i say i don't know what i said
stock footage of sharks
most of the most of the jaws rip-offs
were italian
the main problem with them is they're
dubbing and [ __ ] crazy dialect and
crazy dialogue
[ __ ] up editing and just
but they gave you what you wanted sharks
blowing up people getting eaten by
sharks they'd show you that it's like a
bunch of different ways and that was why
that's why you were going to see that
movie anyway actually i just watched the
last shark the other day uh the rift
tracks version
and that has an amazing scene in it
where the shark basically bumps there's
a dude and standing up in a boat and the
shark like bumps it from underneath and
the boat goes flying and the dude goes
flying up it's amazing and honestly
that's like
um i think uh i was watching the rift
track so i think kevin murphy at one
point he's like he's like man if the
movie was just 90 minutes of that scene
playing over and over again i'm totally
on board with that it was so funny for
me the best jaws rip off is not orca the
best jaws rip off is piranha yeah
because it takes it in another direction
we're gonna go we're gonna go with a
lake fish
uh that is flash eating in a big old
[ __ ]
big [ __ ] school of them
and they're genetically engineered out
of a [ __ ] weird genetically
engineered [ __ ] place out in the damn
mountains i think was out in california
when
and they leave something hanging they
get to the laboratory and a two-legged
[ __ ]
piranha runs across to remember that a
two-legged piranha runs across the
[ __ ]
uh shelf in the damn laboratory because
where they were doing all the genetic
engineering yeah and they never resolved
that they just see it
yeah what happened to that thing yeah i
think we were talking about that on the
piranha they couldn't take it made that
thing was it a piranha or was it a frog
i don't remember it i think it might
have been a two-legged piranha and they
leave you hanging
they never [ __ ] find it again they
never show it well they made sequels to
that i just don't i haven't seen them
yet so i don't know but that one is if
you want to see a good jaws rip off see
piranha that one's a lot that was but
like i said orca is not i wouldn't
necessarily call it a jaws rip-off even
though it was made in response to jaws
yeah it's it's not it's not really the
same it's not really like that at all
it's like an jaws a reverse of jaws in a
way yeah i mean because what you have
you have richard harris playing the sea
captain and i like that they establish
because like i said dino de laurentiis i
like that they established one of the
first things that they do is that
there's two divers
one of whom is charlotte rampling so
again she was just she was in zardoz so
we accidentally saw two movies with her
in it without even meaning to which is
crazy because i forgot that she was in
this one so she's one of the divers
they're down and then there's like a
great white shark comes and uh she gets
off the boat but then like her friend
her the other diver like falls into the
water and the shark's gonna eat him but
then um the orcas come and like whack
the shark out of the water so they save
the guy
so they're
so right there like early on in the film
they're already sort of like look oh
orcas can kick um you know a great white
shark's ass so you know we're it's
scarier than jaws and then they go into
this big long thing about
how intelligent orcas are and how they
have have a capacity for vengeance i'm
not sure if that's true or not but i
don't even know how you would test that
but they are very intelligent so it's
not that crazy um so then richard harris
decides because he was gonna catch a
shark
that but then the whales hit it so he's
like oh well if these whales are so
awesome maybe i'll get a whale and
that'll even cost me more money and then
charlotte rampling is like [ __ ] you dude
it's like you're just gonna you know
they're really intelligent and they'll
probably outsmart you because you're a
dumbass and uh which actually kind of
does end up happening so she tells him
not to but of course he does it anyway
and there's like a whole pod of
of orcas and he shoots at one of them
and meaning to get the mail i guess but
it just like clips the the male's um fin
like dorsal fin
which is nice because then you know it's
the same whale like later on cause he's
got a little notch out of it but then it
hits the pregnant female but he doesn't
know that he brings the female onto the
boat in a really horrible scene honestly
and that was the scene that i think
everybody remembers if they've seen this
movie because it looks i mean obviously
it's fake they didn't kill a real wheel
for this but um it's this whale just
hanging from the bone and bloody and
then this [ __ ] whale fetus like pops
out yeah and like falls up and then they
hose it off the [ __ ] thing and then
they have like the you know the male
whale coming up there and being like i
see you [ __ ] yeah so basically from
then on
the orca is going on a campaign of
terror
to and like i said this is this is what
i was getting at when i was gonna say
you know jaws for the revenge easy solve
problem just go to the midwest where
there's no sharks and you're fine
this one the whale is smart enough
to essentially [ __ ] up the whole village
to get richard harris to come out there
and like fight him like mano amano
because he wants to you know he's like
bring it yeah bro
and so
but but he won't do that at first
because he doesn't believe that the
whale is smart enough
but the whale does all kind of crazy
[ __ ] in this like the whale pretty much
blows up the oil refinery in the in the
town
by
kind of like looking and being like hey
if i hit that little pipe right there
that has gasoline in it and then i hit
this and [ __ ] like that so this is a
really really intelligent whale is what
i'm saying yeah and ends up blowing up
the hole and like kills a whole bunch of
people including the dude from revenge
of the nerds um robert carradine who's
in this for about two seconds before he
gets eaten uh keenan nguyen is in this
for about two seconds before he gets
eaten
um also what's her face is in this too
bo derek it's weird because it's not a
cameo because she's actually it's a
small part but she's in it the whole
[ __ ] movie i'm watching this going
man that chick looks just like bo derek
and then at the end it was like oh it is
bo derek that's probably why it looks
exactly like her but this was like
before she got famous this was before 10
and all that
so
uh so i thought that it was somebody
that looked like her but you know
also this has will sampson in it who
poor guy he always ends up playing like
the magical native american character
which is which he does in this as well
it was his job yeah
he's the one that's just kind of like
you know you [ __ ] do white man it's
like blah blah you know what i mean and
it's like he knows all about the he
knows all about the whales his job was
always to educate the white man on the
spirit world
yeah and that's essentially good at that
though he was in a couple of those damn
um
uh uh clint eastwood movies yeah
remember that
iron man the the white man's word that
some of the bands were made of iron not
on paper what was that what was that
[ __ ] was that outlaw what i think was
outlaw josie wales he shows up in it he
does a great job he [ __ ] knocks it
out of the park
yeah yeah you remember that part do you
no that was yeah i haven't seen i think
it was a josie wales that's when he made
an agreement with josie wales on behalf
of his damn tribe and [ __ ] he was like
the chieftain or main head warrior or
something and i don't remember exactly
what he did made some kind of agreement
i forgot how it played out it was pretty
good he did a good job
he's a good actor it's just that you
know he's typecast he's typecast he's
going to be the indian guy yeah like i
said you're going to be the magic native
american right basically because that's
kind of like the only that's really the
only roles for native americans up until
probably the 90s or later well his face
man
i mean he looked like
the indian chief off of every army army
us army patch
you know what i'm talking about that's
that's exactly what they look like
like he should have been on the damn
second infantry division patch you know
so yeah that's what he's going to be
not like the not like the guy that was
crying over the litter in the commercial
who was actually not even really
american iron eyes cody no that dude was
sicilian wasn't he uh probably i think
he was no i think that actor though also
played a couple sheriffs i think you
played cops too yeah he might like in
the like in the old west or or not west
but uh in the southwest
70's he'd show you you know
because you know that fit that motif too
because that's where the police kind of
looked then yeah mexico and stuff that's
true yeah but yeah so uh so basically
this whale
is
you know holding richard harris's
character for ransom pretty much because
this whole town is like turned against
him because like hey we told you not to
go out hunting killer whales because
you know because [ __ ] like this will
happen uh well actually i think they say
like townspoke are really superstitious
about it and i suppose rightfully so
so they're all so pretty much all the
townspeople are kind of like well you
have to go out there and face this whale
um you know in a one-on-one fight
uh otherwise the whale is just gonna
[ __ ] up their entire town which he
actually kind of does like i said he
blows up a he blows up a oil refinery
like he knocks over richard harris's
house or the house that he's staying in
um he does all that kind of [ __ ] until
richard harris like
dains to go out there in the boat and
fight him now i will say that
um this movie is actually much better
than i remembered and a lot different
than i remembered
but there is some stuff in it that makes
me think that maybe
i don't know because
the character motivations
are kind of like kind of flip-flop
around a lot you know what i'm saying
like charlotte rampling's character
one i don't buy that she would fall in
love with
richard harris's character it's just
there's no chemistry between them at all
so that seemed a little shoehorned in
and weird
um
so you know i will say that
but she's basically
tells him from the jump hey don't one
don't kill any killer whales but of
course he does anyway because he's a
[ __ ]
and then she's like now he's gonna take
vengeance on you and she says all this
stuff like building up the whales as
really intelligent but then after the
whale starts wreaking havoc in the place
then she kind of like changes her tune a
little bit and she's like oh well we
don't actually know what the whale wants
don't give the whale what he wants even
though she told him you need to go out
and fight the whale earlier you know
what i mean so people keep like
reversing their decisions and also
toward the end where
the whale is basically leading richard
harris and the crew
up into you know arctic waters or
whatever
you know in the ice because i guess
they're they're implying that it will be
more evenly matched because he won't be
able to just pop up anywhere and all i
don't know but um so they go up there
and richard harris decides after a
couple of their crew members die like
get eaten
then he's like oh well i'm gonna throw
away my gun and fight the whale on even
terms i'm like what would that
what would that look like a man fighting
a whale on even terms
were you gonna go wrestle it
yeah but then like two seconds later he
picks the gun up again so i don't know
what that was all about actually you
know i was maybe about 35 40 minutes
into this movie and i started kind of
emotionally checking out of it i was
watching it
but kind of being bored it i i thought
i had analyzed what kind of movie it was
and how it was going to feel i kind of
could see what what it was going to do
and it was just kind of stale and
traditional it wasn't a lot of fun i
didn't think
um it's more of a tragedy really than uh
actually and it is a well-made movie for
its time
some people might like it but for me i
kind of felt it was a little too serious
um
and and not very plausible and it did
[ __ ] just like she's talking about he's
going to fight it one on one but he's
going to have that rifle
one on one is you down in the water with
it man
yeah let's have a slap fight yeah
with the whale papa yeah yeah
mano imano
that orca would swallow you in a single
[ __ ] bite that's what i mean it
wouldn't even if it just bites you in
half if they can kill a [ __ ] huge
walrus or a huge [ __ ] seal throw a
[ __ ] seal they could they could take
a 150 pound seal and throw it like 30
feet in the [ __ ] air and when it hits
the ground [ __ ] stuff when it hits
the water stun it so bad they just go
over there and get it
a man wouldn't have a chance not even a
[ __ ] chance against the orca no monoi
motto so that was kind of a
a bold [ __ ] statement right yeah was
he just like saying that he's like oh
i'm not gonna use the gun then like two
seconds later he's like oh well wait
maybe i should yeah
and that's otherwise i'm gonna get my
tiny little ass kicked yeah it was like
a bolt action 30.6 you know and that i
don't think that would be an effective
weapon against the [ __ ] orca to begin
with maybe 50 cal bolt action 50 cal
no
[ __ ] no 308
and honestly through the whole thing i
kind of felt like
halfway through the movie
um you know richard harris is basically
strutting through the first half of the
movie just being a total douche like
yeah i killed the whale yeah oh it was
just an accident i didn't know it was a
female oh well [ __ ] it um i don't
believe they're that intelligent and he
just laughs it off
but then like as the whale starts
[ __ ] [ __ ] up um you know and looks
like it actually knows what it's doing
and it's targeting him specifically
then he's finally like i kind of feel
like they try to make the audience feel
bad for him by saying oh well i guess i
understand where the whale is coming
from because a long time ago like my
pregnant wife was driving to the
hospital
by herself to give birth i'm like and
where were you to drive your pregnant
and in labor wife to the hospital maybe
you should have been driving her but
anyway maybe he was drunk somewhere but
yeah but she got hit by a drunk driver
and killed so it killed her and the
fetus so he's like so i understand that
that's where the whale is coming from so
we're like the same but at that point i
was like look you're already a dick you
didn't feel bad
about killing the whale when after
multiple people told you not to do it to
begin with so i'm just like rooting for
the whale to eat you like so the whole
thing i was team whale um which i guess
you're kind of supposed to be so the
characters aren't super likable so you
don't really feel bad when they all get
eaten yeah jinx says that
uh an orca has never killed a human
being in in the wild
they seem to like humans they killed him
in that captivity but there may have
been accidents or just pissed off bad
day you know well animals i really kind
of feel like um somebody mention
somebody mentioned the um the
documentary blackfish which is kind of
about uh
killer whales in captivity which i still
need to see because
and um and honestly i kind of feel like
yeah those those animals are maybe not
the kind of animals you want to have in
captivity necessarily and doing tricks
and stuff for people they're huge and
they were meant to be out in the open
ocean
and they're communicating each other
with sonar and stuff and you putting
them even in a large even in a large
tank would be like putting human being
in a box or a cell that can't yeah it
just seems really not they're meant to
be traveling and constantly moving
but from everything i've heard of people
interacting with them in the wild they
do actually seem to like humans and they
do seem like curious about them which is
awful weird because uh
i mean all through the victorian era
they were having steam ships and ships
[ __ ] capturing whales and [ __ ]
butchering them at sc
and sometimes they take them back to the
docks you know their whale processing
and stuff and the whales never really
seem to retaliate it makes you wonder
maybe they're not that intelligent or
they have no way of retaliating
yeah remember they don't maybe they
didn't quite understand what was
happening
and some of those photographs from the
1800s i mean we're talking
hundreds and hundreds of whale carcasses
yeah it's horrifying and you're just
like you cannot believe that they were
doing that medium at once they were
using whale oil oil to light houses yeah
so it was a massive industry they were
just massacring them damn
ocean life you know they had no concept
of well we might run out they didn't
really have that that wasn't in there
it wasn't in the in the co in there god
says he'll provide
i don't know what it was
i think it was because he just thought
that things were endless and yeah
endless
production that's all it's okay there's
lots of them look at how many we have
here there's even more on the ocean look
look how big the ocean is we're not even
scratching the surface that's what
they're thinking yeah but they don't
know anything about life cycles or how
old these animals are
you know yeah well what's a fish
and i think that's what they were
thinking you know well this they get big
you know this is probably two years old
and like no man that's probably like a
[ __ ] 30 or 40 year old
whale
so you know they were running out of
them they live um i looked on the
wikipedia page i think killer whales can
live about 90 to 100 years yeah it's a
human-like lifespan because um what i
read and i didn't know this either but
that all those pods and stuff like that
you see are matrilineal it's usually
like a mom and all of her babies and all
the extended ones and then they form
like all these little interconnected
pods yeah and they all have their own
like each community of them has their
own dialect yeah isn't that neat yeah
they all have their own little languages
yeah although that pro this program kind
of gets into it
if that is language i think some of its
vision and processing they're using the
sonar they're using sonar to penetrate
in through creatures and look and see oh
yeah they are they're doing so it's not
all it's not all language some of it
might be signaling but they bring up a
good thing they're like well
language human language is
for our specific needs that's that's
how it emerged
when you have a creature like this who
can actually
send out sonar signals across thousands
of miles or use sonar to penetrate into
an into a fellow
you can see that it's got cancer in it
and all kinds of stuff
they don't need you know
they don't require
words like how are you feeling or like
you're sick or you know what i mean
you've got
it's because their awareness is probably
very different than ours so they don't
need to talk about things that we
actually need to talk about
so it makes you wonder i don't think all
of its language
i think it's just emotions
emotions and they're seeing and they're
responding and then they're sending out
signals and maybe giving information
about where they are or how they feel
it's difficult because if it was an
actual language i think we would have
cracked it by now
because we have all these
computers possibly i mean like i said
their lives are so different to ours
that it's really hard to kind of
extrapolate
what they might be talking about
whatever it is it's artistic
it's not mechanic it's not it's not
based on vocabulary or words it's
something having to do with emotions and
art and they might actually use a sonar
beam that has a bunch of information in
it that it hits the other creature and
they detect it and maybe an image forms
in their mind a vision of what that
creature is talking about
wouldn't that be neat if they did that
it might be something like that yeah
like like a television signal yeah but
it's based on sound and i mean i always
suspect it's something like that i
always thought it was cool too that
they've actually like you know
scientists that have monitored
different uh you know different
communities of whales like across the
globe they have their own like dialects
like they can tell like where that
particular whale came from like what
part of the world because they kind of
essentially like speak different
languages they have like different
sounds for for what appears to be the
same thing louis says i'm pretty sure
the male orcas never leave their mothers
yeah they do um the males usually every
now and then you get one that kind of
goes off on his own like
like a mgtow but yeah but a whale
whales going their own way uh but yeah
most of the most of the male orcas do
stay in their mother's pod yeah they
might have accents but how much you're
going to bet that those tones are just
carrier waves
for something like data or imagery i
have a feeling that they're sending each
other pictures
they're relaying pictures of things that
they're thinking about or things that
they're seeing or relaying pictures
about
the reality like
like text and imagine texting somebody
in a sonic analog way a photo of what
you're seeing yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] like that
probably or things that you want to see
or
the situation like news reports you're
giving out your status what i've been
out here about myself a long time
saw some fish [ __ ] like that where are
you
ate some of guys
use a female
[Laughter]
it's going to be stuff like that where
all the lady orc is that yeah
way over here and then they get an image
of where that where that orca is in the
and that where that whale is in in in in
uh
in uh kind of like uh
in on in the ocean you know what i mean
kind of like coordinates because i mean
those sounds travel a very very long way
right i think in this movie she says
that they can travel all around the
globe i think that's a bit of an
exaggeration but they can travel
thousands of miles though that's just me
thinking this because
the only kind of sonic
way of transmitting information without
words vocabulary and sentence structure
would be data so it must be imagery
imagery and data about emotion
and where your location is that's what
i'm thinking what do you think yeah i
mean i'm sure that's probably what it is
i mean because you have to like you have
to put yourself in the shoes or in the
fins of an orca and what would their
life be like what kind of communications
would they have to send to other ones
yeah because obviously they do it yeah
so
and they have the sensory apparatus to
get an image from a reflected
sonic
wave to get an image in their mind they
can see
and it through things too like x-ray
vision so that means you can beam that
same
[ __ ] sonic wave to another
orca and get an image that's got to be
what it is
the reason why you can't crack it is
because it's it's it's a picture
that's what was said probably a picture
or a representation of a feeling and how
are you going to decode that
not with
the only thing that could do it would be
an orca's brain with its sensory
apparatus
so you you wouldn't be able to do
now if you could tap into its mind
like they did to those cats maybe you
could maybe you'd see that that the orca
is receiving images
but that's which i kind of hope that
they'll be able to do that someday
because i'm actually kind of curious as
to what they're doing out there showing
each other what they're seeing
in their with their eyes and they're
seeing it in their imagination what
they're imagining too
so that would be a [ __ ] badass
creature
a lot of stuff that could be going down
we wouldn't even know anything about it
well yeah they could be saying all kind
of crazy [ __ ] out there we wouldn't know
what they were saying yeah so when
you're talking about that level of
development of the mind you're talking
about personhood
yeah yeah
well like i said they're i mean from
what they can determine
they're along the same lines as higher
primates yeah so our people yeah i mean
pretty much a lot of gorillas and
chimpanzees do things that people do and
they have people they're they're a
person like being
you know so
yeah yeah i'm not so yeah the and the
more that people learn about it i'm kind
of glad that
you know now a lot more people are
pissed off about you know places like
sea world and stuff like that it's like
you know maybe we shouldn't be having
these animals like performing and like
doing all and keeping them in these
small little
yeah if you keep them in there you
should let them go
if they come back you're doing something
right if they're not coming back then
[ __ ]
yeah then they're like [ __ ] you yeah
with their little fins so
because you could always have a good
rela because here's the deal
people say we'll do the same thing with
horses i've raised horses and worked
with them off and on for my whole
[ __ ] life
you let a horse out of it stall it'll
run around until feeding time it'll come
right back to stall because that's where
that horse lives yeah and that's where
all its friends live they're not they're
they they're not wild animals
so
you're keeping them in captivity kind of
like in the same way you keep your
children in captivity by giving them a
place to live yeah
[Laughter]
so it's not captivity the way you think
all right if you let a horse go it'll
run around and let crazy
and then feeding time which is sundown
they come right back
hey where's my bucket where's my bucket
where's my blanket yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i'm gonna they'll go right back into
their stall
and and you shut the door and then all
of a sudden they're relaxed because
nothing can get to them
you know they have to worry about
because they they're a prey animal and
they're afraid of predators so
that's why you shouldn't be capped
no prey no predator animals should be
eaten or or
excuse me predators shouldn't be eaten i
don't believe in it they're a higher
animal you can eat prey animals like
deer and stuff
you can keep a predator as a pet like
big cats and [ __ ] but you shouldn't be
trying to wipe them out and then you're
dealing things like
gorillas and higher primates and orca
and [ __ ] they should be left in the wild
the problem with a lot of this stuff
though is that there is no wild to leave
them in anymore so that's something that
people gonna have to
they're gonna have to make risks yeah i
mean the thing about it i i will make an
exception if the animal is going to go
extinct otherwise
and you have like a breeding program and
you have like actually the [ __ ] set up
for them like an environment set up for
them i don't have a problem with that
yeah but
you can also
populate the earth
as as the earth's human population
declines which it will
conditions for endless growth don't
exist anymore not here we're the result
of a baby boom from the industrial
revolution we're no longer necessary the
oligarchs will wipe us out
over time or it'll happen naturally over
time too
uh
our numbers will decline because it's
just not needed
once that happens all those animals you
have in storage or even if you have
their just dna on file you can
reintroduce them back into the into the
world which that would be the right
thing to do
especially if we're living on another
planet or have colonies on other planets
at that time
jinx says talking about the 52 hertz
whale i think we talked about that on
our audio anomalies i know about that
one show that whale's death
yeah i think that's kind of the main
that's that's the most prevalent theory
that that [ __ ] whale
must be living in a hell if it's death
then that means it's basically blind and
and on its own yeah that's gotta be
pretty bad that's rough it can see with
its eyes but it can't see with sonar
yeah it's not hearing any other messages
so yeah so for all he knows the handicap
so all he knows he's the only whale out
there
and a whale like that would probably be
rejected by the other whales
which
is bad for that whale but it's a good
thing for the whale population because
they don't want
deaf genes to be bred back into the
whale population so they use
animals have a way of saying nope
you're a reject
sad but true
danny rolling ghostface says was
charlotte rampling's character rescued
at the end or was she just stuck on that
burg they showed a helicopter coming at
the end because remember they had called
for uh because they ran out of fuel the
boat ran out of fuel uh and they called
for you know because he said oh there's
a rescue station not that far lowest
yeah so there was a there was a
helicopter then louis says uh there's
videos of orcas hunting sea lions the
way they work together to get them off
the ice is fascinating and dolphins and
orcas are one of the few mammals that
can recognize themselves in mirrors yep
that's true
that reminded me actually because
remember how we've said um about how
pooky looks in the mirror and kind of
talks as though i don't know if she's
talking to herself or if she thinks it's
another cat today what she did i have a
like a piece of art over there that's
like a it's from lucid absinthe and it
has like a black cat on it yeah like an
old art nouveau kind of look
and today i looked behind me and she was
sitting up on the dresser staring up at
that cat on that picture
talking to the cat in the picture she
was going
like to the cat
and she's kind of like trying to she's
been trying to like pull it off the wall
too so i wonder and she doesn't do that
to any of the other framed [ __ ] in here
so i wonder if she thinks that that's an
actual cat like behind a window
and she's like trying to rescue it
cam guy says horses need mental
stimulation they shouldn't be doing the
same thing day after day yeah that's
that's true
but they also like um basically all
animals
uh domesticated animals and horses are
domestic
they've been domesticated for thousands
of years they like
um routine yeah if the routine is is
pookie asks for routines yeah where's
this this this do this one yeah it's
this time of day this time
the routines
are there uh that's how they
uh
have a feeling of progress and moving
forward because they have clocks
so things have to happen
okay and they kind of get stressed out
like when you disrupt the routine
like when we moved yeah you know the
cats acted kind of weird for a little
while until they figured out what was
going on and a new routine was
established and they found out that
everything was okay pretty much all pr
all mammals
will choose
um security over insecurity or they will
choose
uh
certainty over uncertainty so that's
what the routine is they want the
certainty they like it
well and like i said you can understand
that nobody nobody even humans want to
live their whole entire life not knowing
i don't know what's going to happen
what's going to happen that oh is
something bad going to happen where's my
next meal coming from where's the other
that's very stressful so it's really
stressful and horses and horses in a
barn situation and these are all
equestrians you know and thoroughbred
horses they they like being ridden and
they like exercise and [ __ ] they're bred
for that um they also get sent out sent
out the pasture you put them in
different different pads
some of them like to be together with
other ones other ones don't like each
other you kind of want to keep them
separated um
they all are having a herd mentality
experience they're socializing
and
humans are enough to they see humans as
another horse like an alpha horse then
you have your job and you better do it
they want you to do your job
if they see you not doing the job
they'll punish you
you did not replace the water it's that
much it's [ __ ] like that the water is
dirty from last night you forgot to
replace it yeah and they'll they'll act
as
i had dirty water last night god damn it
so they you know they want fresh water
well uh pookie does that as well yeah
they usually have a little water that
they press and it and fresh water will
go in it
but some don't like some of them don't
like it or something will get into fresh
water some hay will fall at it or
they'll accidentally [ __ ] in the fresh
water and they don't want to stick their
[ __ ] nose in there to press the
button to get fresh water because some
of them think they have to drink the
fresh water they don't realize that you
can just push it and let it overflow a
human will understand that you can flush
it out
half the horses that haven't figured
that out that you could just put your
nose in there and it'll flush out over
time and then you can drink it
some of them want the clean water to be
in there always they can't really
swallow so they backwash a lot you know
that's way so they'll you'll see if the
water's green there's nothing in it just
[ __ ] backwash they don't want to
taste it
well i don't blame them yeah nobody
wants to drink their own spit water it's
gross right but other horses understand
that if you just [ __ ] put your nose
in there and hold it down it'll [ __ ]
flow out well just like humans some are
smarter than others yeah and we'll
figure [ __ ] let's figure it out
but yes i mean if you go to the
wikipedia page of about orcas there's
some stories in there that people have
told that you know that go out and study
whales and like some [ __ ] that whales do
yeah um the [ __ ] that they can figure
out they're actually like really smart
they said actually one time this is one
that story that i saw in there where
there was like some people and they were
kind of having a snowball fight and they
said then the whales were kind of like
watching them and then the whales were
kind of like picking up
or smacking little bits of ice
like ice at each other like they were
also having a snowball effect so like oh
that looks like fun but no what i was
gonna say was like this morning
uh pookie's little water fountain she's
got a little water fountain out there in
the hall outside my office and it was
making a lot of noise this morning it
makes a lot of noise if there's not
enough water in it but i guess it also
makes a lot of noise if it needs a new
filter which i'm assuming so it was
making a lot of noise so pookie runs in
the bedroom and like jumps on daddy like
hey my my water fountain there's
something the matter with that you
really need to like come and like see
the situation so we put a new filter in
it and she watched and then she's like
okay
jake is talking about um her working as
a janitor medieval times and seeing the
horses and
stuff and people telling her to eat that
the horses have to smell you to get
comfortable
when you approach a horse you always
want to approach at the shoulder and
stand at the shoulder that's usually how
you'll see horses standing like that you
don't want to approach them head-on
they they don't have an eye in the front
of their heads they don't like things
coming straight at them they like to
wait that's their blind spot like a
blind spot so you want to be up at the
shoulder and if you don't really know
the horse you just might want to stand
there for a few minutes you know touch
the horse let him get to know you and
then reach over and grab the horse by
the muzzle and pull it towards you walk
over and put your mouth right near the
nostril and just start trading breath
when you breathe out he breathes in you
just sit there and just trade breath and
if they start relaxing
then you'll basically own that horse
from there on out
as long as you don't break that trust
sometimes you'll pull away like i don't
really like him not ready you just okay
go back to
stay at the shoulder again let them
relax see if you can do it eventually
they'll go it's kind of like a horse
handshake
eventually okay you're all right
but just trading breath for about two
three minutes four minutes they'll start
to relax and they'll never forget you
after that
because they do that
yeah they'll just have their [ __ ]
muzzles next to each other that's like a
real friendship stuff
you know between horses they'll do that
yeah let's breathe just breathe let's
smell each other's breath
all right so yeah so what did we watch
organ it was amazon prime yeah and i
think you can't get it for free um
[Music]
not legally anyway uh so i think it was
3.99 to rent it weirdly all of these 70s
disaster movies and nature run amok
movies most of them it seems like you
have to pay for it you can't really get
any of them on jesus i'm a male i can't
we can't see you man
well i guess because i think it's just
because of the um of the avatar the
avatar looks like a female kind of well
i mean from far away from far away it's
a little tiny thing so i can't really
tell what it is
but yeah so uh yeah like i said it's
kind of it's not a great movie
but
i i don't think it's seriously on rotten
tomatoes it has nine percent yeah and
i'm like it's not that bad jesus christ
um you know like i said if we're talking
about jaws rip-offs there's way worse
ones than this one this is probably like
the best of the jaws rip-offs how long
have we been streaming almost an hour
okay i got that meat cooking on the
grill i have to get off here in a bit oh
yeah okay yeah we got we got uh actually
you can you can you can end it here i'm
just gonna go down there and get it off
the ground yeah because we're done
talking about we're done talking about
them i'll see you guys later yeah he'll
we'll see you again tomorrow but yeah
we're gonna um i don't know what movie
we're gonna watch tonight like i said we
were gonna watch exorcist 2 but we
couldn't find that for free and tom's
like i don't know if i want to pay to
watch it like if it's as bad as you say
so i don't know we'll see how it goes
but we'll think of a movie tonight to
watch for tomorrow and uh so we'll see
you guys again tomorrow afternoon thanks
everybody for dropping by thanks for
super chats and we'll see y'all tomorrow